This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. No matter how many weddings you've been to, it's hard to shake that contagious feeling of optimism. Couples pledge to love one another in sickness and in health, for richer, for poorer. Family members dabbed tears from their eyes, agreeing that these two people are meant to be together forever. But so many marriages become unhappy, some dissolve, some end in divorce, and even the
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。无论你参加过多少场婚礼，那种具有感染力的乐观情绪总是挥之不去。伴侣们发誓无论生老病死、贫穷富贵都要彼此相爱。亲友们擦拭着眼中的泪水，坚信这两个人注定会白头偕老。然而，有那么多的婚姻变得不幸福，有些分崩离析，有些以离婚收场，甚至那些
successful ones are not without challenges. No one would deny that long-term relationships are hard, and in fact, these evidence, they're getting harder. Over the past few weeks, our relationships 2.0 series has explored new ways to think about how we engage with the people in our lives. We've talked about how to build new bonds with others, how to strengthen the bonds we already have, we've looked at how we can respond to conflict
看似成功的婚姻也并非一帆风顺。没有人会否认长期关系是很难维持的，事实上，有证据表明它们正变得越来越艰难。在过去的几周里，我们的“亲密关系 2.0”系列探讨了看待我们与生活中他人交往方式的新视角。我们讨论了如何与他人建立新的纽带，如何巩固我们已有的纽带，我们还探讨了如何应对冲突，
and how we can work through disagreements more effectively. This week on Hidden Brain, we turn to a favorite episode about marriage. We'll take a closer look at the history of this institution and why our expectations for marriage have changed so much in recent years. Lots of people argue that having these high expectations is problematic and it's harming the institution of marriage. And frankly, among the people who used to argue that is myself. And we'll discuss ways to improve our love lives,
以及如何更有效地解决分歧。本周的《隐藏的大脑》中，我们转向了一期关于婚姻的热门节目。我们将更深入地探讨这一制度的历史，以及为什么近年来我们对婚姻的期望发生了如此巨大的变化。许多人认为，抱有如此高的期望是有问题的，这正在损害婚姻制度。坦率地说，曾经持这种观点的人中就包括我自己。我们还将讨论改善爱情生活的方法，
sometimes by asking more of our relationships, and sometimes by asking less. To understand marriage today, we thought it best to go back to a time and place when marriage was very different. Well, I've been studying the history of family life for many, many years, but I specifically got interested in marriage as we got into these debates about what traditional marriage was. That's Stephanie Koons. She's a professor at the Evergreen State College and the author of the book Marriage, A History. Stephanie says the earliest marriages had nothing to do with
有时是通过对伴侣提出更多要求，有时则是减少要求。为了理解今天的婚姻，我们认为最好回到一个婚姻大不相同的时代和地点。嗯，我研究家庭生活历史已经很多很多年了，但我对婚姻产生具体兴趣是在我们卷入关于什么是传统婚姻的争论之时。那是斯蒂芬妮·库恩茨。她是常青州立学院的教授，也是《婚姻史》一书的作者。斯蒂芬妮说，最早的婚姻与
the feelings of two people or their attraction to one another. As you probably know, marriage was much more about economics and acquiring powerful in-laws. Marriage originally arose in more egalitarian-band level societies as a way of sharing resources and establishing a peaceful relations with groups that you might otherwise only see occasionally and you might not know if they were going to be friends or enemies. It was a way of circulating obligations and goods. I'm marrying my child off to you and that means you owe me things, but I also owe you things. Stephanie brought up a famous example from history, the union between Cleopatra of Egypt and Mark Antony of Rome. Elizabeth Taylor as Cleopatra, siren of the Niles.
两个人的感情或彼此的吸引力毫无关系。正如你可能知道的那样，婚姻更多地关乎经济利益和获取有权势的姻亲。婚姻最初产生于更加平等的部落社会中，作为一种分享资源、与那些平时难得一见、且不知是敌是友的群体建立和平关系的方式。这是一种流通义务和物资的方式。我把我的孩子嫁给你，这意味着你欠我东西，但我也欠你东西。斯蒂芬妮举了一个历史上著名的例子，即埃及艳后克娄巴特拉与罗马的马克·安东尼的结合。伊丽莎白·泰勒饰演克娄巴特拉，尼罗河妖姬。
This is from a 1963 film version. Richard Burton as Mark Antony, rash, impetuous leader of once in Vince the Legion, dreaded adversary on the field of battle. The Hollywood version of the story portrays Cleopatra and Antony as being very much in love, but Stephanie paints a slightly different picture. I think that the theme song for that relationship could have been what's love got to do with it. What's love got to do with it? They may have been passion, but it was more passion for power than sexual, although sexual
这是1963年的电影版本。理查德·伯顿饰演马克·安东尼，鲁莽、冲动的统帅，曾战无不胜的军团领袖，战场上令人敬畏的对手。好莱坞版本的历史将克娄巴特拉和安东尼描绘成深陷爱河，但斯蒂芬妮描绘的画面略有不同。我认为这段关系的主题曲可以叫作“关爱情何事”。关爱情何事？他们之间也许有激情，但那与其说是对性的激情，不如说是对权力的激情，尽管性
probably entered into it too. Cleopatra and Antony's marriage was primarily about strategy. Rome and Egypt were the two most powerful empires in the world. So getting them, anybody who got them together and got an alliance between them would be unstoppable. The story goes that Cleopatra was married to her brother, and without getting into all the details, let's just say she wasn't too happy with that. So she started an affair with Julius Caesar, the ruler of Rome.
可能也参与其中。克娄巴特拉和安东尼的婚姻主要是出于战略考虑。罗马和埃及是当时世界上最强大的两个帝国。因此，让它们结合，让任何人将它们联合起来并促成它们之间的同盟，将是势不可挡的。故事流传，克娄巴特拉曾嫁给自己的兄弟，不扯太多细节的话，只能说她对那段婚姻很不满意。于是她开始与罗马统治者尤利乌斯·恺撒有了外遇。
Cleopatra became pregnant. When the baby was born, he was named Cisarian. The child gave Cleopatra and Caesar a claim to each other's throne. It was something they both desperately wanted. Sounds like an episode of Game of Thrones, right? Well, then Caesar died, and Mark Ampeney came along. And of course, the story tells that she should dost him. But, you know, when you really look at what was happening practically, this was another political alliance. First, as did Caesar.
克娄巴特拉怀孕了。孩子出生后，被取名为恺撒里昂。这个孩子给了克娄巴特拉和恺撒对彼此王位的宣称权。这是他们俩都极度渴望的东西。听起来像是《权力的游戏》里的情节，对吧？好吧，后来恺撒死了，马克·安东尼出现了。当然，故事说她征服了他。但是，你知道，当你真正审视实际发生的事情时，这是另一个政治同盟。首先，就像恺撒那样。
You will marry me according to Egyptian ritual. It's not a condition that's a reward. You will declare by your authority, the Syrian to begin a Egypt. And we will rule together in his name. Siserion was too young to rule, and Anthony could rule in his place. So it was a great big political alliance,
你将按照埃及的仪式娶我。这不是一个条件，而是一个奖赏。你将以你的权威宣布，恺撒里昂是埃及的继承人。我们将以他的名义共同统治。恺撒里昂太年轻，无法统治，安东尼可以取而代之进行统治。所以这是一个巨大的政治同盟，
just like Game of Thrones. This marriage strategy was unjust for kings and queens. There's a common misconception that people of lower classes in this time married for love. Not true, Stephanie says. You couldn't run a farm with one person. You couldn't run a bakery with one person. So people who were bakers married other bakers.
就像《权力的游戏》一样。这种婚姻策略对于国王和女王来说并不罕见。有一个常见的误解，认为这个时期的底层人民是为了爱情而结婚。斯蒂芬妮说，并非如此。一个人是经营不了一家农场的。一个人也经营不了一家面包店。所以，面包师会和其他面包师结婚。
If you were a peasant, you wanted somebody who had a good reputation as a hard worker. And that was much more important than this frivolous luxury as the way it was really thought of as how attracted you were to the person. A different idea started to become more common in the 17 and 1800s. Jane Austen, the famous novelist, may well have been the trailblazer. For those who don't remember the plot of her book, Pride and Prejudice, Mr Darcy, who has been promised in marriage to his wealthy cousin, falls instead for Elizabeth Bennett, a woman of modest means. That throws his aunt into a rage. Mr Darcy is engaged to my daughter. Now what have you to say? Only this if that is the case,
如果你是一个农民，你会想要一个有好名声、吃苦耐劳的人。这比那种被视为轻浮奢侈的东西——也就是你对这个人的吸引力有多大——要重要得多。一种不同的观念在17和18世纪开始变得更加普遍。著名小说家简·奥斯汀很可能是开拓者。对于那些记不清她的书《傲慢与偏见》情节的人来说，本已被许配给富有表妹的达西先生，却转而爱上了家境 modest（注：原文 modest 对应经济条件一般）的伊丽莎白·贝内特。这让他的姑妈勃然大怒。达西先生已经和我女儿订婚了！现在你有什么话说？只有这些：如果是这样的话，
you can have no reason to suppose he would make an offer to me. You selfish girl! This union has been planned since they infancy! Do you think it can be prevented by a young woman of inferior birth? Heaven and earth are the shades of pemblyty with us polluted? Now tell me once and for all are you engaged to him? I am not. So, Stephanie, talk about this. This is the first glimmers, if you will, of the idea that in some ways love was coming to conquer marriage. This clip you used is perfect because it illustrates the fact that
你就没有任何理由认为他会向我求婚。你这个自私的女孩！这桩婚事从他们婴儿时期就已经订下了！你以为凭借一个出身低微的年轻女子就能阻止它吗？天地良心，彭伯里的树荫竟因我们而玷污？现在告诉我，一次性告诉我，你跟他订婚了吗？我没有。那么，斯蒂芬妮，谈谈这个吧。这可以说是爱情开始征服婚姻的最初微光。你用的这段剪辑非常完美，因为它说明了这样一个事实：
men found it easier to embrace the love match than women did. Men could marry down because they could go out and earn wages. Women had to be very, very cautious. You know, as you can say, my heart inclines to Harry, but you know, I'd better marry who my parents want me to and the person who is most likely to be able to support me. And so there was a prolonged period of time where men actually were more romantic than women in the courtship, Aurena.
男人比女人更容易接受爱情婚姻。男人可以向下结婚，因为他们可以出去赚钱。女人必须非常非常谨慎。你知道，正如你所说，我的心倾向于哈利，但你知道，我最好还是嫁给父母希望的那个人，嫁给最有可能养活我的人。因此，在求偶期，曾有一段很长的时间，男人的浪漫程度实际上超过了女人。
By the second half of the 19th century, the Jane Austen model of marriage had taken firm hold in the United States. The idea of marrying for anything other than love came to be seen as old-fashioned. And with the rise of this new idea came another. If marriage was once seen as a partnership between people from similar backgrounds and similar social classes, the new model of marriage began to celebrate the coming together of people who were supposedly radically different from one another. And you got this new theory that love was a union of opposites. The idea came that men and women were totally different and you could only have access to the emotions, resources, abilities of the other by getting married and staying married. You were incomplete without it.
到19世纪下半叶，简·奥斯汀式的婚姻模式在美国牢固确立。除了爱情之外，因任何其他原因而结婚的想法都被视为过时的。随着这一新观念的兴起，另一个观念也随之诞生。如果说婚姻曾经被视为背景相似、社会阶层相近的人之间的伙伴关系，那么新的婚姻模式开始赞美那些被认为彼此截然不同的人的结合。于是你得到了这样一个新理论：爱情是异质的结合。当时的观点认为，男人和女人是完全不同的，你只有通过结婚并维持婚姻，才能接触到对方的情感、资源和能力。没有它，你是不完整的。
In practice, this dovetail with a changing economic landscape in the country, where men increasingly became the breadwinners and women became homemakers. The 1950s sitcom, Leaver to Beaver, makes clear this division between male and female roles. Well, however we cook inside, mom always says we cook outside. But whenever we cook outside, you always do it. How come? Oh, it's sort of traditional, I guess.
在实践中，这与该国不断变化的经济格局相吻合，在这一格局中，男性越来越多地成为顶梁柱，而女性则成为家庭主妇。20世纪50年代的情景喜剧《留给海狸》清楚地展现了男性和女性角色之间的这种分工。好吧，无论我们在里面怎么做饭，妈妈总是说我们在外面做饭。但每当我们在外面做饭时，你总是自己动手。为什么？哦，我想这算是一种传统吧。
You know, they say a woman's place is in the home and I suppose as long as she's in the home, she must have long as she's in the home she might as well be in the kitchen. Oh, that explains my mom. How come you always do the outside cooking? Well, I'll tell you son, women do all right when they have all the modern conveniences, but us men are better at this rugged type of outdoor cooking. So I'll throw back to caveman dates. Talked to me by this idea, Stephanie. So clearly, gender biases played a role
你知道，他们说女人的天职在家里，我想只要她在家里，她就必须——既然她在家里，她不妨待在厨房里。哦，这解释了我妈妈的情况。为什么总是你在外面做饭呢？嗯，我告诉你儿子，当拥有所有现代便利设施时，女人做得很好，但我们男人更擅长这种粗犷的户外烹饪。所以我这是回到了穴居人时代。和我说说这个想法，斯蒂芬妮。很显然，性别偏见在
in how we came to think about marriage. Well, absolutely. But what's interesting about this clip is that the concept of the male breadwinner was unknown before the 19th century. Women worked in the home, but so did men. And men didn't go out and bring home the bacon. Women helped raise the pig. Maybe the man butchered it,
我们如何看待婚姻方面发挥了作用。嗯，绝对是的。但这段剪辑有趣的地方在于，男性顶梁柱的概念在19世纪之前是未曾听闻的。女人在家里工作，但男人也一样。而且男人也不是出去把熏肉带回家。女人帮忙养猪。也许男人把它宰了，
but the woman often cured the bacon and took the bacon to market. So again, this was part of this new idea of love that I talked about earlier. The idea that men and women were so different that the man had to do all the outside stuff because the woman couldn't do it and the man had to do all the outside stuff, because the woman couldn't do it, and the woman had to do all the inside stuff, because the man couldn't do it and wasn't supposed to do it. The idea of the love match may have been controversial at first, but when concerns were raised about how people from different backgrounds would stay together, when they didn't have the bond of shared work, or the larger framework of a shared community,
但女人通常会腌制熏肉并把熏肉拿到市场上卖。所以，这再次成为了我之前谈到的关于爱情的新观念的一部分。这种观念认为，男人和女人是如此不同，以至于男人必须做所有外面的事情，因为女人做不了；而女人必须做所有里面的事情，因为男人做不了，也不应该去做。爱情婚姻的观念起初可能是颇具争议的，但是，当人们开始担心背景不同的人在没有共同工作的纽带或广阔社区的宏观框架的情况下将如何维系在一起时，
advocates for love marriage said men and women would stay together because they needed one another to feel psychologically complete. This theory was later appropriated in romantic stories and movies. Think of the saying, opposite, subtract. But as the divorce rate in America surged in the 1970s and 80s, many started to think that what you should look for in a mate was not your opposite, but someone who shared your interests and values. It wasn't quite the same as one baker looking to marry another baker, but more along the lines of people marrying others with similar educational backgrounds and similar cultural and political attitudes.
爱情婚姻的倡导者们表示，男人和女人之所以会在一起，是因为他们需要彼此来获得心理上的完整。这一理论后来被浪漫的故事和电影所借用。想想这句谚语：异性相吸。但随着美国在20世纪70和80年代离婚率飙升，许多人开始认为，你在伴侣身上寻找的应该不是你的对立面，而是与你有着共同兴趣和价值观的人。这与一个面包师想娶另一个面包师不太一样，而是更类似于人们与具有相似背景、相似文化和政治态度的人结婚。
You know, it's important to understand that love itself, the definition has changed. It's different today than it was at the beginning of the love match when it was a union of opposites. And today, it's really like a union of people who share so many values. And that's one of the big challenges of love today, because we spend a hundred years trying to get people to see a difference as erotic and the source of love. And now our big challenge is how do we make equality erotic? How do you make equality erotic? Where is the sizzle in consensus and compromise? In childcare pickups and doctors appointments, in a lifestyle symbolized by a Honda Civic, rather than a flashy Ferrari.
你知道，重要的是要理解爱情本身，它的定义已经改变了。今天的爱情与爱情婚姻之初——当它被视为异质结合时——已经不同了。而今天，它真的很像是一群有着如此多共同价值观的人的结合。这也是当今爱情的一大挑战，因为我们花了一百年时间试图让人们将差异视为具有情色魅力的来源和爱情的源泉，而现在我们面临的巨大挑战是如何让平等变得具有情色魅力？如何让平等充满吸引力？共识和妥协在哪里能带来激情？在接孩子放学和看医生的预约中，在一个象征着本田思域而不是耀眼法拉利的的生活方式中。
When we come back, we'll answer that question. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. We've been talking with Historians Tefiny Koon about how marriage changed from an institution that was primarily about economic partnerships and political experience to one based on romantic love. Once this shift took hold in the United States over the course of the 19th century, love marriages became the norm. Soon, everyone wanted to know the secrets of making love last.
当我们回来时，我们将回答这个问题。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。我们一直在与历史学家斯蒂芬妮·库恩茨探讨婚姻是如何从一个主要关于经济伙伴关系和政治利益的制度转变为一个基于浪漫爱情的制度的。一旦这种转变在19世纪的美国扎根，爱情婚姻就成为了常态。很快，每个人都想知道让爱情持久的秘密。
You've seen those documentaries and news stories about elderly couples who've managed to stay together for most of their lives. Meet Milt and Leora, sweet hearts for life. We've been married 60 years, 60 beautiful years. When people ask me how long have you been married, I truthfully say not long enough. A heartwarming documentary about the life of a couple that has been together for three quarters of a century, 75 years. There's something that those stories don't tell you.
你见过那些关于老年夫妇的纪录片和新闻报道，他们设法相守了一生的大部分时间。来见见米尔特和利奥拉，一生的甜心。我们已经结婚60年了，60个美好的年头。当人们问我你们结婚多久了，我实话实说，还不够久。这是一部温暖人心的纪录片，讲述了一对相伴四分之三个世纪（75年）的夫妇的生活。有些事情是这些故事没有告诉你的。
Social psychologist Eli Finkel at Northwestern University has studied the psychological effect of the historical changes that Stephanie has documented. Eli is the author of the All or Nothing Marriage, and he has a very dramatic term for the challenge that many couples face today. Modern marriage, he says, runs the risk of suffocation. To understand that term, Eli says you have to look at yet another shift that started in the 1960s and 70s. We wanted to complement our emphasis on love, achieving love through marriage, with a new emphasis on achieving a sense of personal fulfillment in the way of personal growth. So in the terminology of
西北大学的社会心理学家伊利·芬克尔研究了斯蒂芬妮所记录的历史变迁所带来的心理影响。伊利是《要么全无的婚姻》一书的作者，他用了一个非常戏剧化的词来形容当今许多伴侣所面临的挑战。他说，现代婚姻面临着窒息的风险。为了理解这个词，伊利说，你必须看看始于20世纪60和70年代的又一次转变。我们在强调爱情、通过婚姻获得爱情的同时，又增加了一个新的重点，即通过个人成长的方式获得个人成就感。所以在
psychology, we wanted to self-actualize through our marriage, we wanted to grow into a more authentic version of ourselves. One example of this comes from the best-selling book by Elizabeth Gilbert about walking out on her husband and trying to create a more meaningful life for herself. We're going to play a few clips from the movies as we chat and this one comes from the movie Eat, Pray, Love featuring Julia Roberts. We'd only bought this house a year ago. Hadn't I wanted this? I had actively participated in every moment of the creation of this life. So why did I see myself in any of it?
心理学的术语中，我们希望通过婚姻实现自我实现，我们希望成长为一个更真实的自我。这方面的一个例子来自伊丽莎白·吉尔伯特的一本畅销书，讲述了她离开丈夫并试图为自己创造更有意义的生活。在我们聊天时，我们将播放几段电影片段，这段来自由朱莉娅·罗伯茨主演的电影《美食、祈祷和恋爱》。我们一年前才买下这所房子。难道这不是我想要的吗？我积极参与了这个生活创造的每一个瞬间。那为什么我在其中的任何地方都看不到自己？
The only thing more impossible than staying was leaving. It sounds like she was searching for her true selfie line. Yeah, that's exactly right. She in some sense helps to epitomize both the strengths and the weaknesses of this modern contemporary approach to marriage, where we're looking to our spouse, again, not only for love, but also this sense of personal growth and fulfillment. And for the first time, you start to see cases where people would say, as I think Liz Gilbert would say, that she was in a loving marriage and he was a good man and treated her well, but she felt stagnant and she really wasn't willing to endure a stagnant life for the
唯一比留下更不可能的事就是离开。听起来她是在寻找真正的自我。是的，完全正确。在某种程度上，她体现了这种现代当代婚姻方法的优点和缺点，在这种方法中，我们向配偶寻求的不仅仅是爱情，还有这种个人成长和成就感。并且你第一次开始看到这样一种情况，正如伊丽莎白·吉尔伯特可能会说的那样，她处于一段充满爱的婚姻中，他是一个好男人，对她很好，但她感到停滞不前，她真的不愿意在接下来的30或40年里忍受一种停滞不前的生活，于是她离开了。
next 30 or 40 years and she walked out. This would have been unthinkable, of course, a hundred years ago, let alone 500 years ago. Yes, this would have been a very, very bizarre thing to say. And marriage, you know, it wasn't really until the 70s that you started seeing no fault divorce laws. It used to be that you had to prove some type of serious mistreatment like abuse or desertion.
当然，这在一百年前是不可想象的，更不用说五百年前了。是的，这会是一件非常非常古怪的事情。而且婚姻，你知道，直到20世纪70年代你才真正开始看到无过错离婚法。过去，你必须证明某种严重的虐待行为，比如虐待或遗弃。
Yes, it's a very modern idea that we are entitled to a sense of real fulfillment and personal growth through the marriage, and if our marriage is following short, many of us consider it to be a reasonable option to end the marriage for that alone. You come up with what I think of as a riff on a very famous psychological concept. Many years ago, Abraham Maslow proposed that human beings have a series of different needs that begin with physical security and end with a search for meaning and fulfillment.
是的，这是一个非常现代的想法，即我们有权通过婚姻获得真正的成就感和个人成长，如果我们的婚姻达不到这一点，我们中的许多人会认为仅凭这一点就结束婚姻是一个合理的选择。你提出了一个我认为是对一个非常著名的心理学概念的改编。许多年前，亚伯拉罕·马斯洛提出人类有一系列不同的需求，从生理安全开始，到对意义和成就感的追求结束。
And you say that a similar hierarchy has come to describe how many Americans think about marriage. Tell me about what you call Mount Maslow. Well, one of the most exciting things that happened to me in the process of writing the book is I learned a lot about the history and the sociology and the economics of marriage, particularly reading people like Stephanie Koens, because my primary expertise is as pretty much a laboratory psychologist. I bring couples into the laboratory and I videotape them interacting and I follow them over time, but these other disciplines, scholars and these other disciplines adopt a different approach. So I realized that marriage had in fact changed radically
而你说，类似的等级制度也成为了许多美国人看待婚姻方式的写照。跟我讲讲你所说的“马斯洛山”是什么。嗯，我在写书的过程中发生的最激动人心的事之一，就是我了解了很多关于婚姻的历史、社会学和经济学知识，特别是读了像斯蒂芬妮·库恩茨这样的人的书，因为我的主要专业背景基本上是一名实验室心理学家。我把伴侣们请进实验室，将他们互动的过程录像，并对他们进行长期跟踪，但其他学科的学者和这些学科采用的是不同的方法。所以我意识到，就我们对婚姻满足我们需求（在美国）的期望而言，婚姻事实上已经发生了根本性的变化。
in terms of the way we expect it to fulfill our needs in America, that is. And it used to be that marriage was about basic economic survival. We've seen that from Stephanie Coons and others. And you can think of that as being at the bottom of Maslow's hierarchy toward the physiological and safety needs, really survival-based needs.
过去，婚姻关乎基本的经济生存。我们从斯蒂芬妮·库恩茨和其他人那里看到了这一点。你可以认为这处于马斯洛需求层次的底部，即生理和安全需求，也就是纯粹基于生存的需求。
And then, as we track marriage, and it becomes more about love, now we're more toward the middle of Maslow's hierarchy. And then, in the 1960s, and then really up until today, we're in this new era where, yes, we're still looking for love, but now we're toward the top of Maslow's hierarchy, where he's talking about things like esteem and self-actualization. And so our expectations of marriage have basically ascended from the bottom to the top of Maslow's hierarchy over the course of American history.
然后，随着我们对婚姻的追踪，它变得更多地关于爱情，现在我们更多地处于马斯洛需求层次的中间。然后，在20世纪60年代，一直持续到今天，我们进入了一个新时代，是的，我们仍在寻找爱情，但现在我们处于马斯洛需求层次的顶端，他谈论的是诸如尊重和自我实现之类的事情。因此，在整个美国历史的进程中，我们对婚姻的期望基本上从马斯洛需求层次的底部攀升到了顶端。
And one of the ideas that emerged, as I was writing this book, is that we can conceptualize Maslow's hierarchy not just in terms of a triangle, but in terms of a mountain, right? And the advantage of thinking of Maslow's hierarchy as a mountain in this way is that it brings to mind a number of metaphors related to mountaineering. And one thing that we know when we climb up a big mountain is the views get increasingly gorgeous as you get to the top, but the oxygen gets a little thinner. And so having a successful experience way up there at the top requires that you are able to invest a lot of oxygen, either bring extra oxygen with you on the mountain,
在我写这本书的过程中，出现的一个想法是，我们可以不仅从三角形的角度，而且从山峰的角度来概念化马斯洛的需求层次，对吧？以这种方式将马斯洛需求层次想象成一座山的优势在于，它让人联想到许多与登山相关的隐喻。我们都知道，当我们攀登一座大山时，越往上走，景色越发壮丽，但氧气也变得越发稀薄。因此，要在山顶获得成功的体验，要求你能够投入大量的氧气，要么在山上随身携带额外的氧气，
or invest a lot of time and energy in the marriage to succeed up there. So to continue your analogy, if we want to get to the top of Mount Mads Lowe, but we have failed to bring our oxygen tanks with us, that's what leads presumably to what you call the suffocation model. That's right, that's right, that is, that is, it's lovely way up there at the top, and if we're looking to try to achieve not only the sense of love and connection, but also the sense of personal growth and authenticity through the marriage,
要么在婚姻中投入大量的时间和精力，才能在那里取得成功。因此，延续你的比喻，如果我们想登上马斯洛山顶，却没有随身携带氧气瓶，这大概就会导致你所说的“窒息模型”。没错，没错，也就是说，山顶上的风景确实美不胜收，如果我们不仅想在婚姻中获得爱与连接感，还想获得个人成长和真实感，
but we're trying to do it on the cheap. And that disconnect is what I'm talking about when I talk about the suffocation of marriage. What I love about that analogy is it makes physical almost this psychological process, this effect of our expectations. All of us can imagine what it would be like to suddenly wake up one morning and decide, you know, I'm going to run a marathon or I'm going to climb a mountain, a very tall mountain without really any preparation. And we will recognize that it's not just difficult to do, but potentially foolhardy. That is exactly right. I think if we think about what we're really asking of our marriages these days, in terms
但我们又想以最低的代价做到这一点。而这种脱节，就是我谈论婚姻窒息时所指的内容。我喜欢这个比喻的地方在于，它将这个心理过程、我们期望产生的这种影响变得几乎是有形的。我们所有人都可以想象，如果有一天早上突然醒来，决定：“你知道吗，我要去跑马拉松，或者我要去爬山，一座非常高的山，却没有任何准备。”我们会认识到这不仅难以做到，而且可能十分愚蠢。
of the ambition of these expectations, then we realize that if we're too tired or lazy to invest in the quality of the relationship, that of course we're not going to be able to make the summit attempt. Of course, we're not going to be able to make the summit attempt. Of course we're not going to be able to succeed in meeting those expectations toward the very high end of Maslow's hierarchy. And so the book talks a lot about how we can in fact align what we're asking of the marriage with what the marriage is realistically able to offer us. for us. So there have been a few people, Eli, over the years, who've tried to explore the same ideas that you have. Esther Perel, of course, comes to mind. In her famous TED talk, she summarizes some of these challenges, and I want to play your short clip. So we come to one person, and we basically are asking them to give us what once an entire
完全正确。我想，如果我们思考这些天我们对婚姻的真正要求，考虑到这些期望的宏伟程度，我们就会意识到，如果我们太累或太懒，不愿投资于关系的质量，那么我们当然无法发起登顶尝试。我们当然无法发起登顶尝试。我们当然无法成功满足那些处于马斯洛需求层次极高端的期望。因此，这本书花了很多笔墨探讨我们如何能够将对婚姻的要求与婚姻实际能够提供给我们的现实保持一致。所以，伊利，多年来有一些人试图探索和你一样的想法。埃丝特·佩瑞尔当然就是其中之一。在她著名的TED演讲中，她总结了其中一些挑战，我想播放你的一小段剪辑。所以我们走向一个人，我们基本上要求他们给我们提供曾经由整个村庄
village used to provide. Give me belonging, give me identity, give me continuity, but give me transcendence and mystery and all in one. Give me comfort, give me edge, give me novelty, give me familiarity, give me predictability, give me surprise, and we think it's a given and toys and lingerie are going to save us with that. So I love that passage, Eli, but you talk about the same idea in your book.
才能提供的东西。给我归属感，给我认同感，给我延续性，但还要给我超越感和神秘感，把这一切融为一体。给我舒适，给我刺激，给我新鲜感，给我熟悉感，给我可预测性，给我惊喜，而我们认为这一切是理所当然的，以为玩具和内衣就能拯救我们。我喜欢那段话，伊利，但在你的书中你也谈到了同样的观点。
You give the analogy of a woman who once turned to five different friends for important things she needed, but once she gets married, she turns to our husband for those same five things, and he's not able to provide all of them, and she feels now unfulfilled. That's right. In the research literature on how we achieve our goals, there's a clunky word called multi-finality, and this is the idea that a given means can serve multiple goals. So for example, when I walk to work,
你打了个比方：一个女人曾经向五个不同的朋友寻求她需要的重 要帮助，但一旦她结婚了，她就把这同样的五件事都转向她的丈夫寻求，而他无法提供所有这些，于是她现在感到了不满足。没错。在关于我们如何实现目标的研究文献中，有一个拗口的词叫“多重效用”，这个概念是指单一的手段可以服务于多个目标。例如，当我步行去上班时，
that might simultaneously meet my need to get to work, but also my needs to get some fresh air and get some exercise. And so this one activity can serve all sorts of functions. What's interesting is that's really what we've done to marriage, right? Is that marriage for a long time served as set and relatively limited array of different functions for us?
这可能同时满足了我去上班的需求，但也满足了我呼吸新鲜空气和锻炼身体的需求。所以这一个活动可以服务于各种各样的功能。有趣的是，这实际上就是我们对婚姻做的事情，对吧？婚姻长期以来一直为我们服务于一组相对有限的不同功能？
And over time, we've piled more and more of these emotional and psychological functions. So instead of turning to our close friends and other relatives for nights out on the town, for deep intimate disclosure, to a larger and larger extent, our spouse has replaced a lot of what we used to look to our broader social network to help us do. You know, as I read your book, Eli, I realize that it's not just what we expect from our partners that's changing. We also now expect that we can unlock special things in our partners.
而随着时间的推移，我们堆积了越来越多的情感和心理功能。因此，我们不再向密友和其他亲戚寻求夜晚外出的陪伴、深度的亲密倾诉，而是在越来越大的程度上，我们的配偶取代了许多我们过去依赖更广泛的社交网络来帮助我们做的事情。你知道，当我读你的书时，伊利，我意识到不仅我们对伴侣的期望在改变。我们现在还期望我们能够激发伴侣身上的特殊品质。
And this is also reflected in the movies. The 1997 movie as good as it gets has a scene where a woman who is fed up with, you know, put down by her, by the man who's trying to woo her, demands that he give her a compliment. Okay. Here I go. Clearly a mistake. I've got this, what? Alment. My doctor, a shrink that I used to go to all the time, he says that in 50 or 60% of the cases, a pill really helps.
这也在电影中得到了反映。1997年的电影《尽善尽美》中有这样一个场景：一个女人受够了试图追求她的男人的贬低，要求他给自己一句赞美。好吧。我来了。显然是个错误。我有这个，什么？病。我的医生，一个我过去常去的心理医生，他说在百分之五十到六十的病例中，药片确实有帮助。
I hate pills. My compliment is that night when you came over and told me that you would never... All right, well, you were there. You know what you said. Well, my compliment to you is, the next morning, I started taking the pills. I don't quite get how that's a compliment for me.
我讨厌药片。我的赞美是，那天晚上你过来告诉我，你永远不会……好吧，你在那儿。你知道你说了什么。好吧，我对你的赞美是，第二天早上，我开始吃药了。我不太明白这怎么能算对我的赞美。
You make me want to be a better man. That's maybe the best compliment of my life. I found this so revealing in the context of your bookie lie, Helen Hunt's character is telling Jack Nicholson's character that the thing that makes her feel really good is not what he does for her, but what she can do to unlock something special in him. Yeah, he is smitten with her and his desire for her, his being impressed with her and the desire to make her like him more, actually makes him want to grow into a better person. And in some sense, that's the absolute archetype of what we see in contemporary marriage. Today, we're looking for a spouse to bring out the ideal version of us, the latent version that's inside of us that we can hopefully grow into with enough time and effort.
你让我想要成为一个更好的人。这也许是我一生中得到的最好的赞美。在你的书的语境下，伊利，我发现这太启迪人心了：海伦·亨特饰演的角色告诉杰克·尼科尔森饰演的角色，真正让她感觉很好的东西不是他为她做了什么，而是她能做些什么来激发他身上某种特别的东西。是的，他对她神魂颠倒，他对她的渴望、对她的印象以及想让她更喜欢自己的愿望，实际上让他想要成长为一个更好的人。在某种程度上，这就是我们在当代婚姻中所看到的绝对原型。今天，我们寻找配偶是为了带出我们的理想版本，也就是潜藏在我们内心深处的那个版本，只要有足够的时间和努力，我们希望能够成长为那个版本。
You have a wonderful term in your book. You call this the Michelangelo effect. Yeah, this is a term I actually got from my doctoral advisor, Carol Rusbalt. Many of your listeners will know that the Michelangelo, when he talked about the sculpting process, talked not in terms of revealing or sculpture, but in terms of unleashing it from the rock in which it's been slumbering. So the sculptor's job is not to create something new, but merely to refine and buff and polish and maybe scrape away the rough edges of what was already nesting within the rock. That's a really good metaphor for how partners today try to relate to each other. That is, all of us have an actual self, the person that we currently are.
你的书里有一个美妙的词。你称之为“米开朗基罗效应”。是的，这个词其实是我从我的博士生导师卡罗尔·鲁斯博特那里学来的。你的许多听众会知道，米开朗基罗在谈到雕刻过程时，他所谈论的不是创造或雕刻，而是将它从沉睡的岩石中释放出来。因此，雕刻师的工作不是创造新的东西，而仅仅是打磨、抛光，也许是刮掉那些原本就嵌套在岩石中的粗糙边缘。对于现在的伴侣如何建立联系，这真是一个很好的隐喻。也就是说，我们所有人都有一个现实的自我，也就是我们目前的样子。
But we also have an ideal self, a version of ourselves that's aspirational. Like, what could I maybe become if I could be the best version of myself, and we look to our partners to be our sculptors, to help us until we actually grow toward the best ideal version of ourselves. So Eli, do we actually have this power, this power to place culture and bring out the best in someone else?
但我们也有一个理想的自我，一个具有抱负的自我版本。比如，如果我能成为最好的自己，我可能会变成什么样？我们指望我们的伴侣成为我们的雕刻师，帮助我们，直到我们真正成长为最好的理想版本。所以伊利，我们真的有这种力量吗，这种塑造并激发他人最好一面的力量？
The answer is yes, we do have this power, but it's not easy to do, and not everybody is compatible, and sometimes the version of you that you want to grow into isn't the version of you that I want you to grow into. And this is a very delicate dance that we play. And, you know, the best relationships today, the sorts of relationships that I call the all relationships and the idea of the all-or-nothing marriage, they're well aligned in this sense. They're able to bring out the best in each other and connect in a way that facilitates each other's personal growth and therefore helps to produce a really profound amount of emotional connection and psychological fulfillment.
答案是肯定的，我们确实有这种力量，但这并不容易做到，不是每个人都兼容，有时你想成长成的那个版本并不是我希望你成长成的版本。这是一场我们之间进行的非常微妙的舞步。你知道，今天最好的那些关系，也就是我称之为“全包关系”以及“要么全无的婚姻”理念的关系，在这方面是高度契合的。它们能够激发出彼此最好的一面，并以促进彼此个人成长的方式进行连接，从而产生令人惊叹的情感连接和心理满足感。
Many marriage experts say that high expectations are the enemy of happiness in marriage. You come to a slightly different conclusion. You say that it's true that on average, many marriages might be unhappy today than they were half a century ago, but that isn't true of all marriages. Who are the exceptions? The exceptions are people who bring those expectations and are able to meet them. This is, I think, the crux of the entire issue.
许多婚姻专家表示，高期望是婚姻幸福的敌人。你得出了一个略有不同的结论。你说，虽然平均而言，今天的许多婚姻可能比半个世纪前更不幸福，但这并不适用于所有婚姻。例外是谁？例外是那些抱有这些期望并能够实现这些期望的人。我认为这是整个问题的核心。
Lots of people argue that having these high expectations is problematic and it's harming the institution of marriage. And frankly, among the people who used to argue that is myself. I, when I set out to write this book, thought I was writing a book about the decline over time in marriage and how we're throwing more and more expectations on this one institution and this one relationship, but we're not investing enough time. And therefore, we've really created a seriously problematic approach to marriage. And it wasn't until I reviewed these other scientific literatures and learned more about how things
许多人认为，抱有如此高的期望是有问题的，这正在损害婚姻制度。坦率地说，曾经持这种观点的人中就包括我自己。当我着手写这本书时，我以为我写的是一本关于婚姻随着时间推移而衰落的书，以及我们如何将越来越多的期望压在这个单一的制度和这段单一的关系上，却没有投入足够的时间。因此，我们确实创造了一种严重存在问题的婚姻方法。直到我审阅了其他科学文献并更多地了解了事情是如何变化的，我才意识到这其实只是一半的事实。
have changed that I realized that's really half the story. It is true that we are asking a lot more especially when it comes to these more psychological and love-based needs than we did in the past, but some marriages are able to meet those needs. And so what does it mean if you have a marriage that you're looking for to meet these very highest level needs, say for example, in Maslow's hierarchy, and the marriage succeeds in doing so? You're able to achieve a level of fulfillment
诚然，我们在过去没有做过的事情上提出了更多要求，尤其是在这些更偏向心理和爱情导年的需求方面，但有些婚姻确实能够满足这些需求。那么，如果你的婚姻正在寻求满足这些最高级别的需求（例如马斯洛需求层次中的需求），并且婚姻成功做到了这一点，这意味着什么呢？你能够在婚姻中实现一种满足感，
in the marriage that would have been out of reach in an era where we really weren't even trying to meet those types of needs. So at the same time that these high expectations are waiting us down and making it more difficult to achieve a healthy marriage at the same time, that a marriage that would have been acceptable to us in 1950 is a disappointment to us today because of these high expectations, those same expectations have placed within reach a level of marital fulfillment that was out of reach until pretty recently. So this idea that some people invest heavily in their marriages, at the expense of careers
而在我们甚至不试图满足这些类型需求的时代，这种满足感是遥不可及的。因此，尽管这些高期望让我们不堪重负，使得在今天实现健康婚姻变得更加困难，但与此同时，1950年我们可能觉得可以接受的婚姻在今天却会让我们感到失望，正是因为这些高期望，同样的期望也让我们触及了直到不久前还遥不可及的婚姻满足感水平。所以这个想法，即有些人为了事业和朋友、甚至可能是为了孩子们的活动而大量投资于他们的婚姻，你说这在另一部电影的场景中得到了完美的体现。在《杯酒人生》中，保罗·吉亚玛提饰演的葡萄酒鉴赏家向他的爱慕者解释了黑比诺和赤霞珠的区别。你为什么这么迷黑比诺？我的意思是，这就像是你的一个情结。我不知道。我不知道。我不知道。它是一种很难种植的葡萄。
and friends, maybe even, you know, their children's activities, you say this is perfectly captured in a scene from another movie. In sideways, Paul Jermade's wine connoisseur character explains to his love interest the difference between a Pino and a Cabernet. Why are you so into Pino? I mean, it's like a thing with you. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. It's a hard grape to grow.
如你所知，对吧？所以它皮很薄，性格敏感，成熟得早。它不像赤霞珠那样是个生存专家，赤霞珠随处都能生长，甚至在被忽视时也能繁茂生长。黑比诺需要持续的照顾和关注。事实上，它只能在世界上这些真正特定的、隐蔽的角落里生长。而且只有最具耐心和培育能力的种植者才能真正做到这一点。
As you know, right? So it's thin skin, temper metal, ripens early. It's not a survivor like Cabernet, which can just grow anywhere and thrive even when it's neglected. Now, a peanut needs constant care and attention. In fact, I can only grow in these really specific little tucked away corners of the world. And only the most patient and nurturing of growers can do it, really.
只有真正花时间了解黑比诺潜力的人，才能引导它展现出最完美的表现。然后，我是说……哦，它的风味，简直是地球上最令人难忘、最辉煌、最惊艳、最微妙和古老的。所以，伊利，当我们听到这个并在婚姻的语境下思考这一点时，为什么我们不都想种植黑比诺呢？嗯，我认为我们很多人对黑比诺都应该相当谨慎。我的意思是，我认为那个剪辑在为过去50年或更长时间里美国婚姻如何改变提供一个隐喻方面，做得简直无懈可击。婚姻已经从一种近似于赤霞珠的制度——它随处都能生长，甚至在被忽视时也能繁茂生长——变成了一种更加娇嫩、脆弱的制度，需要大量的照料和维护。
Only somebody really takes the time to understand Pino's potential, can then coax it into its fullest expression. Then, I mean... Oh, it's flavors, they're just the most haunting and brilliant and thrilling and subtle and ancient on the planet. So, of course, Eli, when we hear this and we're thinking about this in the context of marriage, why wouldn't we all want to grow Pino? Well, I think a lot of us should be pretty careful about Peno. I mean, I think that clip does an absolutely masterful job of providing an analogy to how marriage has changed in America in the last, say, 50 years or more. It's changed from an institution approximating Cabernet, which can just grow anywhere and
所以你问我，谁会想要除了黑比诺以外的其他东西，至少根据迈尔斯对那些葡萄的看法是这样。而我会说，相当多的人可能不想处理那种脆弱而娇嫩的东西。但是正如他所说，我们当中那些真正搞懂了的人，也就是当有正确的种植者和正确的背景时，它的风味就是那么令人难忘、辉煌、微妙而古老。我认为他想表达的意思是，这是一种需要高维护成本的葡萄。它需要大量的工作。如果你不够小心和专注，
thrive even when it's neglected, to a much more delicate, fragile institution that requires a lot of tending and maintenance. So you ask me, who would ever want anything other than Pinot Noir, at least according to how miles thinks about those grapes. And I would say, a whole lot of people might not want to deal with something that fragile and delicate. But like he says, those of us who get it right, that is, and he's talking about the grapes, when there's the right grower and the right context, the flavors are just haunting and brilliance and subtle and ancient. And what I think he's saying is, this is a high maintenance grape. It takes a lot of work. And if you aren't careful and attentive,
你就会对它感到失望，它会让你失败。但如果你付出足够的努力，你就能拥有真正精致的东西，而这正是我们今天所处的“要么全无的婚姻”的现状。你的书得出的结论之一是，当我们要应对我们中的许多人都想登上马斯洛山顶，却没有投入时间、精力或耐心去真正到达那里的挑战时，我们在某种程度上拥有两个主要的替代选择。在你的婚姻中，你描述了一次西雅图之旅，在那个比喻中，你发现自己极度缺氧。
you're going to be disappointed in it, it's going to fail you. But if you work hard enough, you can have something truly exquisite and that is where we are today with the Aller-Nothing Marriage. One of the conclusions of your book is that we have in some ways two major alternatives when it comes to dealing with this challenge that many of us want to be at the top of Mount Maslow, but are not investing the time and effort or the patience to actually get there. In your own marriage you describe a trip to Seattle where in your own analogy you found yourself starved of oxygen.
你会对它感到失望，它会让你失望。但如果你付出足够的努力，你就能拥有一种真正精致的东西，而这正是我们今天面对的“全有或全无”婚姻。你书中的结论之一是，在应对这一挑战时，我们在某种程度上主要有两种选择：许多人希望达到马斯洛山顶，却又没有投入时间、精力或耐心去真正到达那里。在你自己的婚姻中，你描述了一次去西雅图的旅行，在用你自己的比喻时，你发现自己缺氧了。
That's right. We went through a hard time. I in particular went through a hard time with the adjustment to parenthood. And I frankly, I think that the reason I had a hard time is the sort of stuff that I'm talking about in the book. I hadn't sufficiently calibrated or recalibrated my expectations to what life would be like with a newborn. And the research on this is, in fact, tricky.
Obviously having a bundle of joy is a wonderful thing and you love the new baby like crazy and kissing that little fuzzy head is one of the most satisfying things we ever get to do in our lives. But the reality is a recent estimate suggests that it's about 33 and a half additional hours a week of extra time, like of care that goes into that. And I would ask the couples out there listening who don't have a kid, where would those 33.5
hours a week come from? And then you're complimenting that with some sleep deprivation and, frankly, much less time for emotional connection or sexual connection with your spouse. And you're complimenting that with some sleep deprivation and, frankly, much less time for emotional connection or sexual connection with your spouse. And is it any surprise that the research evidence shows that the arrival of the first baby tends to be pretty hard on the quality of the relationship, on the marital satisfaction, for example. And it was during that period where we took a trip to Seattle to see my closest and longest-term friend.
One of these life experiences that has always been a source of bliss and joy for me throughout the, you know, 30-some-odd years of my life at the time. And I was miserable. It turns out that traveling across the country with an eight-month-old is not anything like traveling across the country without an eight month old is not anything like traveling across the country without an eight month old. And then you're together with your best friend and there's all the stuff that you used to do. But now there's an eight month old there and you're not doing any of those things. And I really had a hard time.
I mean, I can't really exaggerate this. I really struggled emotionally with the adjustment. And I said to my wife, and I regret saying this, it's hard for me to say out loud right now, you know, I can endure this. Like I can get past this, and I certainly love my daughter, but I need to stop trying to have fun, because if I'm trying to enjoy my life, and I'm trying to enjoy you, I keep end up disappointed. And she was very upset about that. And, you know, I made her cry. I'm trying to enjoy you, I keep end up disappointed. And she was very upset about that. And, you know, I made her cry. I'm not proud of this at all. But she cried and
thought, what is this the end of us trying to live a good life together? Are we just going to hunker down and be unhappy together? But the truth is this ended up being the lowest point, but also the starting of where I started to recover a little bit, it took that moment before I started to get serious about making life better again. And one of the major ways I did it was by recalibrating my expectations, yes, but also reinvesting in a way that made sure that I was more connected to my wife than we had been, and it took some work. And it did require that we lower expectations in some ways
and then try to meet those lower expectations and we were in fact able to do it but it certainly wasn't easy. Eli and other researchers have found that it's not especially easy to fulfill a partner's emotional and psychological needs when you're struggling to pay the bills or working three jobs. This might be one reason that the institution of marriage appears to be especially fragile among low-income couples. When we come back, we're going to look at tangible solutions. If you can't afford to take your partner on that romantic trip to Paris, but you still want to get to the top of Mount Maslow, we'll show you how to get there.
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. On today's show, Marriage. Marriage is what wins us together today. That's right, marriage. Marriage, that blessing arrangement, that dream within our dream. The priest from that iconic scene in the Princess Bride describes it best. What does he? We're taking a look at how marriage has evolved over time from a partnership of necessity
to a union of two very different people who need one another's love to be complete, to the all or nothing relationships identified by psychologist Eli Finkl. Eli argues that our expectations for marriage, both gay and straight, among rich and poor, have dramatically increased. Couples who are able to meet these higher expectations are happier than couples have ever been. But couples who fall short are unhappier than their counterparts a century ago. Eli says there are things we can do, what he calls love hacks,
to reorient how we think about marriage and make ourselves more fulfilled in long-term relationships. Some of your listeners might be fans of Marcel Proust, who argues that mystery is not about traveling to new places, but about looking with new eyes, and the love hacks are exactly that. There are ways that we can try to experience the same relationship, but view it in a different way, and therefore be a little bit happier in the relationship itself. So psychologists have long talked about something called the fundamental attribution era, which is sometimes when we see someone behaving away that we don't like, there's two ways to interpret it.
You can either say this person is behaving badly because they're a bad person or you can say this person is behaving badly because there's something in the context. There's something happening around Himoher that's causing Himoher to behave this way. And one of the hacks that you suggest is to reinterpret negative behavior from your partner in a way that's more sympathetic rather than critical. Right. And I'm not saying it's magic.
I'm not saying it's the easiest thing to do, but I'm saying that with some effort we can get a little better at this. So your spouse is late, your spouse is disrespectful, I mean, ideally not in a huge way, but your spouse does something inconsiderate, you have a lot of control over how that behavior affects you. And in particular, you have control over whether you want to explain that behavior in terms of something about your spouse that's maybe stable and a character or a logical assessment. Like my spouse is always such a jerk. You can try instead to say, look, my spouse was a jerk just now,
but he's under a lot of stress at work. Or you can think, look, he probably tried the best he could. There was probably some traffic or some crisis at work. I'm just gonna let it ride. Now, I'm not saying these are easy things to do, because we do have a default to explain other people's behaviors as elements of their character. But the fact is, and we should be better at understanding this, there are all sorts of things that contribute to
why somebody engaged in one behavior over another behavior. And we have some control over the extent to which we interpret our partners in considerate or rude behavior in a way that's more generous and kind, and the kinder approach will make us happier in the relationship, and our partner will probably be happier too. You also think that having what you call a growth mindset is a useful thing. What do you mean by that? So the psychologist Carol Dweck at Stanford, she's developed this idea that people differ
in terms of how they think about various attributes. So she studies intelligence, for example. And people differ in the extent to which they think intelligence is something that's fixed and stable and you have it or you don't. Versus, it's malleable and it's something that you can develop over time. Well, it turns out there's a lot of good research now on the extent to which people feel like compatibility in a relationship is something that is fixed. You know, you could call this a destiny mindset. People who think, look, partners are either compatible or they're not, and that's the end of the story, versus more of a growth-oriented mindset. Who think, look, there's a lot of room where you can develop compatibility, and in fact, going through difficulties in a relationship isn't a signal that, oh my goodness,
we're incompatible people. It's an opportunity to learn to understand each other better and strengthen the relationship through the resolution of the conflict. And here again, it's not like we have complete control over the thoughts that we have about these things, but we can try to make ourselves adopt a more constructive growth-oriented approach to thinking about conflict in the relationship rather than a more destiny-oriented approach that can often view conflict as a deep sign of incompatibility,
and that's pretty destructive for the relationship. You also talk about more serious alternatives, so if people find over time that they are just incompatible with one another, and yet they have these high expectations of different things they want from their life, you suggest that one of the alternatives might be to develop systems where people are actually getting different things from different people. That's right. It's the same logic again, right? So we have this all or nothing approach.
We expect these high-level things, and many of our marriages are, in fact, falling short of that. So one possibility is that we try to invest more in the relationship and the second possibility, which we've called Love Hacks, is how to be more efficient. But the third possibility, and I actually think we should be pretty serious about this. There's nothing shameful about making these sorts of sacrifices. We should ask less. In what ways can we, in our own marriage, look to the relationship and see, man, like I have been looking to fulfill this sort of need
in the relationship for a long time, and I'm chronically a little disappointed about how we do as a couple and helping to fulfill this sort of need, is there some other way that I might be able to meet this need I have, either through some other friends or even on my own? And there's some research by the psychologist Elaine Chung at Northwestern University that looks at what she calls social diversification.
Can you diversify your social portfolio, if you will? And she looks at the people we turn to when we're feeling emotions that can help us regulate those emotions. So, to whom do you turn when you're feeling sad? To whom do you turn when you want to celebrate your happiness? And she assesses how much people look to a relatively small number of people to do all of those things, versus a larger number of people. And she finds across a range of studies now that people who've diversified their social portfolio,
that is, turned to different sorts of people for different sorts of emotional experiences, tend to be a little bit happier. And so, with regard to marriage in particular, we've really lumped a lot of our emotional fulfillment on this one relationship. And for many of us, we would benefit, and our marriage would actually benefit if we asked a little bit less in some respects. I love the idea of diversification and the analogy with financial diversification. I mean, so the idea, of course, is that you might have, you know, bonds in your portfolio and they don't do very well and they don't grow a lot, but they're very stable. And then you might have some stocks in your portfolio that are high growth, but they also
have the potential for losing a lot. And what you're suggesting is that by having different things accomplish different parts of what you need, your portfolio as a whole ends up being more stable than if you put all your eggs in one basket. You know, that's right. And that's a neat way of thinking about it that I hadn't fully processed previously. In some sense, what we're doing with marriage these days is we've got a heavily stock-loaded portfolio.
And that means that when the market is up, we make huge gains. But that's a lot of eggs to put in that one basket. And when the market goes down, we're going to get hit pretty hard. And to some degree, that's also a reasonable metaphor for the self-expressive marriage, where we look to one person to fulfill so many of our emotional and our psychological needs, the payoff can be huge, but there's a lot of risk. Now, for people to actually consider diversifying their portfolio romantically and emotionally, presumably this also creates stresses on what we think of as marriage. So if people are looking outside the marriage for emotional support or other needs,
some people are going to say, well, are you really married anymore? I think this is a valid question, and this is a complexity that comes up when you think about how an institution like marriage changes over time. I suspect that if somebody transported from 1750 to today, they might look around and say, whoa, that doesn't look like marriage. I don't even really get what you guys are doing, or better yet, if we transported back to 1750
and looked at what people were expecting and how little they were looking for personal fulfillment from the marriage, we would be bewildered. were looking for personal fulfillment from the marriage, we would be bewildered. So, one of the more controversial ideas that I play with in the book is when I'm talking about ways that we can ask less of the marriage. By the way, when I am doing that, I'm talking about how can we strengthen the marriage by asking less of it, one of the places that I consider is in the romantic or sexual domain. So is it reasonable for some people to consider some type of consensual non-monogamy?
Now this is not cheating, that's the whole idea of consensual non-monogamy. This is an understanding that we don't need to have complete monogamy all the time. And you can negotiate an alternative. In fact, among millennials, this is becoming an increasingly common way of thinking about the ideal relationship. So this is an ideal option, especially for people who generally are connecting pretty well
and they love each other and they're good co-CEOs of the household together, but they're really struggling to sustain a mutually satisfying sex life together. Those are particularly good opportunities to consider could we reduce some of the disappointment and pressure by opening up the relationship in some ways that we can both agree to. It's certainly a high risk option, but it's an option that probably will benefit some relationships.
You see that you and Allison have developed a shorthand of sorts for the times that you want to communicate affection, but are stoved of time. And it has to do with this song. It's pretty nice girl, but she doesn't have a lot to say. I'm not just Jesus, pretty nice girl, but you changed from day to day. I want to tell her that I love her a lot, but I've got to get a belly full of wine. I'm not just Jesus, pretty nice girl, so they want to make it. That's Paul McCartney at the end of the Abbey Road medley. It's like a little 23 second bonus track. And it's interesting. I haven't heard it in a while,
and even as I listened to it, as you just played it, I sort of teared up a little bit because it's been a very significant song for my wife and me in our marriage. When we were first dating, you know, people are falling in love and they often say, I love you or whatever, but I was very partial to this idea of belly full of wine, right?
I want to tell her that I love her a lot, but I got to get a belly full of wine. And idea of belly full of wine, right? I want to tell her that I love her a lot, but I got to get a belly full of wine. And eventually saying belly full of wine was our little replacement for, I love you. And what was neat about the way we used the phrase belly full of wine is it was able to contain like a whole terabyte of information about love and respect and affection in this like one second phrase. We could turn to each other and just say belly full of wine and just really communicate so much information in that very little, just those few words. And this is an example of a broader idea that we don't appreciate enough, which is that every marriage has its own culture, that has its own language and its own expectations,
and we can leverage the features of how culture works to benefit the marriage with a sort of emotional shorthand that can help express affection, and it can be especially crucial. If you're going through a difficult time and maybe things are getting a little hot and maybe you're on the verge of a fight, and you can say,, baby, belly, belly full of wine and you might be able to diffuse some of what could have been a pretty problematic episode. Eli Finkill is a social psychologist at Northwestern University. He's the author of the All or Nothing Marriage, How the Best Marriages Work. Eli, thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
Thank you so much for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For our unsung hero today, we turn the mic over to you, our listeners. Our story comes from Deb Merchant. Our unsung hero is Scott Stevens, her partner of 22 years.
In 2003, Scott and I had been dating for just a couple of years when I was diagnosed with breast cancer. And I gave him the choice to opt out of the relationship. And he didn't hesitate to say, no, we're a team. We're doing this together. And so we did. After biopsy and tomoxifen and radiation, the doctor said, we'll never see you again. A couple of years later, however, the cancer came back, and this time it was a different matter. This involved many surgeries, and in January 2007 2007 I started six months of chemotherapy. Our first visit,
there were 10 or 12 of us all receiving chemotherapy that day as we look through the windows out towards the Cascade Mountains. I thought for sure that Scott would drop me off head back to his office to continue his work and come pick me up at the end of the day. And instead he stayed with me all day. Got me through being comfortable in a chair with the right pillow and warm blanket, making sure I had the right food and tea. And then he went to the next person and asked them, are you comfortable? Can I get you anything? Would you like a warm blanket or pillow?
How about some hot tea? And then he went to the next person and the next person and the next person. And I thought maybe the first day that that would be it. But he stuck with me every single week through chemotherapy and he went to every single person in every single chair, We went to every single person in every single chair, every single week throughout that entire period. Scots, care and love of people comes first. He's actually said to me, I'll take love over money any day. And he demonstrated that during our time, when we went through chemotherapy together.
And because of him, I'm doing great today. It's his commitment to be present for someone he loves that made a huge difference in my life and that's why he's my unsung hero. Deb merchant and Scott Stevens live in Albany, Oregon. In their spare time, they love to hike, snow shoe and camp in the Cascade Mountains. Deb has been cancer-free for the last 13 years. If you liked this episode and would like us to produce more shows like this, please consider supporting our work. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org.
Again, if you would like to help support the show you love, go to support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.